hey we haven't heard from the Kansas
troll for a while he's back on our
voicemail line at two one nine two david
p the kansas troll if you're not
familiar with him and many people may
not be because he's only he's dropped in
and out of our audience callers for many
many years he used to leave wildly
racist and outrageous voicemails for a
very long time and we'd play them every
once in a while and then he dropped off
the face of the david pakman show for
some time he resurfaced during live
calls trying to make some very strange
point about me selling supplements or
coffee like alex jones or something like
that
how'd that go and it didn't go that well
for him it became a total face plant
because i I think he thought I was gonna
get it really flustered and tried to get
him off the phone but I actually was
interested in talking to the Kansas
troll I kept him on and he totally
face-planted yeah you gave him the
platform right yeah we were like say
your piece now that was your chance and
he couldn't do it it didn't go very well
and then we didn't hear from him again
for quite some time he has resurfaced
with more of the same identity politics
that I guess he claims to be against
take a listen to this hi I just wanted
to give a short and brief analysis of
you and your show okay basically you are
the epitome of the modern beta male you
are a slowly filled cuckold and new male
when you speak David I can hear the
estrogen boozing from your pores I think
it's very evident that your girlfriend
wears the pants in the relationship yeah
you know those aren't arguments those
are attacks on my identity and I am
against identity based attacks
I don't believe if I am a beta soy boy
whatever that is not an argument against
any of the assertions I make on the
program and I am against identity
politics and thus I am NOT going to
respond in kind I think the Kansas troll
has to go back under the bridge where he
lives you don't like it okay he's got to
start telling riddles again I find it
him interesting I find this guy
fascinating I wonder what his life is
like and you know he's been calling the
show for like five six years I don't
know how old this guy is but I am really
curious about how has his life changed
if at all during the time he's been
calling into the show
what does he do what's it like living in
Kansas I don't know I think he also just
calls other shows like he called in to
the majority report a while ago and that
didn't do so well he was hugely
embarrassed when he called Sam cedar
anyway good to hear from the Kansas
troll despite being called a soy boy
whatever beta male today's bonus show is
a very good one we will talk about the
great news that Trump's military parade
has been suspended again we will talk
about the Satanic temple once again
protesting Christian monuments with
their goat-headed statue but befo MIT I
think it's called Baphomet I never know
how to say it we'll also talk about the
fact that there are more than 5000 US
troops in Iraq and they're going to be
there for a long time
join the David Pakman show membership
program and get access to the bonus show
at WWE at medCom you can also make a
pledge on patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and you will also get
access to that same world excuse me I'm
just so excited about the bonus show I'm
joking that same world-famous
bonus show speak to you then